Okay,
we are back live.
Hello.
Evening stream.
Two hours. 2 hours 40. No, two hours 20
minutes. Probably probably finish around
9.
We're going to see what we can get done
on this refactor.
That's the idea.
I'm going to try to just get this thing
like.
We'll see how much progress I can make.
But yeah, I really want to have a full
prototype of this thing by the end of
the day tomorrow. So hopefully I can get
a good chunk of this done. Otherwise,
I'm just gonna have to like really block
everything else out and do this all day
tomorrow.
And I'd like to have some time for other
stuff. So, let's get started on this.
Uh, where do we go?
Okay. We were working on this ridiculous
string [ __ ] right? I've always said
like the one thing that annoys me in C
is string processing.
It's just such an obnoxious operation to
have to do.
Let me see if I can just like
Hang on. I have to actually look a
couple things up for this probably.
Uh pass 2D
they pass 2D char array.
What's the sig
array of 10?
Because it's fixed, right?
That's not bad.
How do you in general avoid nesting for
loops when writing code? Why would you
need to avoid nested for loops?
Whoops.
Okay, I didn't do this label right, but
we can fix that.
in Python a lot.
So that's the problem. Yeah, that's not
faster. It like or not that much faster.
That's the problem. If you're trying to
do an operation that requires nested
looping and it's not easy to write as an
array ops, you're using the wrong
language.
I can write whatever the health loops I
want in C and it's fast.
See, that's the problem with Python,
right? It gives you new stupid problems
to solve instead of just like getting
good at using the small set of tools
that are like fast and actually work. It
gives you new problems to solve because
it introduces a bunch of new tools at
the price of making everything else slow
as hell.
The hell?
Uh,
six ticks.
I will admit string processing in C kind
of sucks.
I don't understand why this is still
like this.
Oh, dummy.
Yeah. All right.
That's just me being tired.
There we go.
Okay. So, let's see what we ended up
with here.
I don't think we ended up with
particularly less code.
I think we kind of just ended up with
more [ __ ]
If we put these two functions back into
the draw Hex.
That's so obnoxious though.
Come back to it.
I think I like
I like squashing all the data for this.
I could probably do like an add like a
blend additive or something on this.
I can probably like do everything
composited and get this nice
Yeah, this is kind of crap as well,
isn't it?
I have a lot of stuff that's crap in
There.
Finally, I could run my environment in
Puffer Lib 600 KPS. An immense joy.
There you go.
How should I use Puffer Lib on
discovering phase?
Well, we can get even faster than 600k
if you have a decent GPU, I'm sure. So,
all right, let me hang on.
All right, so you're going to need to
learn to read this plot. So, this plot
says you're only spending 3% 4% of the
time on the environment. So, like trying
to make the environment faster doesn't
help you much. Copy here means that it's
actually spending a decent chunk of the
time copying data back and forth. This
is kind of a puffer thing, but if you
have obs that are over a few hundred
bytes, then uh you can probably reduce
it to make it faster. Other than that,
this is the amount of time spent in the
forward pass of the neural net during
data collection. This is miscellaneous
time. This is forward pass during
training, learning time, copying data
around in miscellaneous. So, you can
kind of see where your bottlenecks are.
Um, if you have a fast env, you're going
to want to have pretty large batch and
mini batch sizes. Check our defaults.
We're usually using like, you know,
32,000 somewhere between 8 and 32,000
mini batch sizes and we have like 4,000
plus parallel environments. So, it's a
really large scale compared to what
you'd be used to. Um, but the thing is
it's just it's so fast that who cares
about steps, right? You care about
solving your problem fast. Um,
so yeah, you're going to want to do that
for Perf and then just run puffer
sweeps. Learn how to use puffer sweeps
because protein is our sweep algorithm.
It's really, really powerful. Uh, and
other than that, yeah, enjoy, right?
Like, don't be afraid to read the code.
The code's really short. Puffarel is
pretty much the entire training thing.
It's one file. It's like a 1200 line
file, but only the top 500 lines are the
actual algorithm. The rest is like
logging and stuff.
That's Puffer.
And Puffer is getting even faster and
even better every update. That's what
I'm here working on every day.
Then the thing that you've been watching
me work at uh work on on stream, right?
Constellation.
This is going to be the largest scale
visualization toolkit for RL. Like look
at this. Wi super slow, can't handle a
bunch of data points. Boom. We have all
our data points, right? everything you
possibly want to look at. Many M's, many
metrics, right? We're gonna have
everything right in here.
470 super going to convert. Oh, it's
600K even in Python. H. So, yeah, look
at that little percentage number next to
your N. And if that's significant, then
you can make it faster. And see,
that's so funny. You have 600K in
Python.
Oh, that's funny.
If you haven't I don't know if you've
done low-level dev before, but if you
haven't, absolutely learn some low-level
dev. Lowle dev rocks. It honestly like I
was starting to get kind of down on
programming. Like, I'm being real. Um
cuz I'd written Python for 10 years and
just like I didn't feel like I could
build everything I wanted. Everything
kind of felt slow and clunky. and
low-level dev has just reignited that.
And I just love love building stuff
again.
And also, this shader looks so cool.
This shader is so cool. It's probably
not the best for actually looking at
data. And I'm going to have to add a
toggle for like boring mode, but come
on. You can't tell me this does not look
so cool.
Python is second. Then what have you
been doing? Screw Python.
What are you doing? You literally know
you know kung fu.
Go beat him up.
I gotta like go pay Exordev because the
uh the effect is based off of like the
actual why it looks so good is based off
of the attenuation by Exordev. I'm going
to go drop him like a hundred bucks or
whatever for this cuz I used one of his
like his public shaders.
He doesn't even have a buy button on his
shaders, but I'll go drop him something.
Anybody tried Doom? Okay, so mechanics.
If you want to do Doom, there is a
binding and I found there's a hidden
setting in Doom that's not in the
binding that everybody uses that lets
you render it at a really low
resolution. They have like a potato
resolution in there. And I think I got
it to like I got it to some pretty
reasonably high FPS. You can definitely
get over a 100,000 FPS on Doom if you
want to do it.
All right. How are we going to handle
all this log transform crap?
I'm kind of conflicted here, guys.
Because like
you can kind of see what happens right
when I do like when I make plotting
functions and I try to make them general
like this is a general draw ticks okay
because it just takes like labels
but then you're tied to this plot
obstruct which I guess I can like keep
tweaking.
The thing that's kind of gross to me is
I think I'm going to end up with more
code if I refactor it this way.
Like I'm thinking, okay, maybe plot
three shouldn't have all this crap
associated with it, right? And we'll
just make it like
[Music]
it's like basically every single time
you want to make the thing general or
whatever,
I'd end up having to copy all the data
again.
custom torch encoder did for oceans.
It depends on your uh it depends on your
environment XF.
So what the way to think about it is you
want to match the encoder to your
environment. So if your encoder has if
your environment has 2D data, you
probably need columns, right? If your
entire if your data is just flat and
it's like continuous, you can just use
the flat encoder. If you have discrete
data, then you need to oneh hot it. So,
it's not so much like, well, what policy
is better? It's just you want to fit an
encoder to your data,
it will nerd snipe you. I do have to
refactor it. It just me depends what
direction uh like what direction I go.
If I just like leave this as is and I
walk away from this project, this is
going to be unusable in 4 days.
Like, I definitely have to clean it up.
It's just a question of what direction
do I go in?
Bicycle kinematics. I see.
Uh
well, but it depends on just like what
your data is, right? If you have like if
you go look at your data and it looks
like pong or if it looks like drone or
whatever where it's just like state data
that's not associated with any
dimension, it's continuous. It doesn't
need to be discreet encoded. Then you
just use your flatten bed and you're
good.
I think I want to freaking do this.
I mean, you can't possibly look at this
and tell me this is an okay signature
for a plot function, right?
But at the same time, like having
plotting library abstractions actually
feels wrong now that I've been building
this stuff in C, right? like you end up
having to do so much more data
transformation and [ __ ] when you
have uh an API that gives you like a
plot function.
We're going to think about this a little
bit now because this is going to drive
me nuts otherwise. I was thinking like,
oh, I could make like a little plot
library and see, but the thing is like
having a plot function, you're already
kind of screwed, aren't you?
Well, because it's like okay the plot
function it supports logging any axis,
right? Um there's the camera which you
need to transform the data uh from 3D to
2D because of the shader
because we're not using just like 3D
draw function.
There's filtering, right? There's like a
filter on it. There's a color map on it.
Which like it's better to have a color
map like this than it is to have an
array of color strcts technically, isn't
it?
But this is completely gross. And also
having like a plot function that takes
hyper
is also gross,
readable and humane to use. Yeah, but
then think about it, right? Then like
instead of just like filling the value
normalized value that I want to convert
to color, now I have to write an extra
loop in order to call the plot function,
right? I have to write an extra loop to
convert the color uh instead of a value.
And then if you pass a cap instead of
passing colors, then you lose the buil
the ability to do custom colors.
And then at some point it's like what
the hell are you even doing? Cuz like if
you're going to make it so general, the
function gets to be like 10 lines.
So it's like why do you even have a
function where you're going to have to
redo all these buffers when the function
doesn't even do anything?
[ __ ] I hate abstraction.
Okay, like this one is correct, right?
The only one I actually am sure about is
the plotgl function,
funny enough.
Why am I sure about that one? That's a
good question. Let's go interrogate
that.
Oh, yeah. I'm sure about that one cuz
it's a mess of OpenGL nonsense.
And you don't ever want to have to
freaking touch this. You just give this
thing the shader and you give it
vertices, right? And then it goes and
draws it for you.
That's like the only thing in here that
actually feels good.
2% envin evaluate. Is that fine? Yes.
Yes. Fiber. 2% M time is reasonable.
You don't get zero unless you're doing
double buffering, which I guess is
sometimes default, but
yeah, that's fine.
Well, XF8, it kind of depends on how
nice this is, right? If I get a really
nice plotting library about this, then
from this, then I'm going to use it on a
ton of stuff.
If I get some garbage that's like
completely single purpose or if I get
not garbage but if I get something
that's like totally single purpose with
no like nothing I can remotely reuse.
But in my mind, like reuse,
like making something reusable shouldn't
mean ah in order to reuse this you have
to change the way that you would write
it if you weren't going to use this
function, right?
Well, I mean, go for like, yeah, think
about it and like do stuff. Sure, that's
fine. I'm fine spending time on this,
but the [ __ ] do I do?
I mean, I guess
Well, hang on. I guess what if I do what
if I combine filtering?
I could combine if I take an array in I
could combine filter log map to screen.
I think they're going to be some
primitives out of this.
[ __ ] it. I'm going to have fun with
this. We're going to actually do some
stuff on this tonight. It'll be good.
Here, we'll do um let me use a restroom
and we'll do impromptu
impromptu pull-up set and then uh we
continue. Welcome, Major.
I'll be right back. We'll show off the
pull-ups.
Yeah, just throw it all in strs.
1.6K. Let's say 1.5.
[Music]
Nice pull up form.
Six reps with uh 45 pounds of weight.
Solid enough.
>> Well, Major, we do. It's just the
question is
I'm getting kind of stuck on.
So I like this plotg function, right? It
just takes points and puts them to the
shader. But like look at this plot
function. It's disgusting.
Well, then you'd also have to do for log
as well.
Super obnoxious.
It's like so obnoxious.
John Carmarmac. Yeah, that would be
awesome.
That would be awesome.
I've honestly been thinking about just
like
reading some of his code just to see
what the hell I'm missing.
He wouldn't be staring at this like how
do I refractor this, right?
Like, am I just stupid or is this
nonobvious though, right? Like, what the
[ __ ] do you actually do with this?
Is it Do you need an axis? Is that what
the thing is?
why am I trying to refactor this code?
I want to get this thing polished up and
I'm hoping that I end up with like some
semi- general or like some semi-reusable
plotting interface out of the project at
the same time, right?
You know, I could see this becoming
constellation C and plot.h,
Like it's not entirely uncommon for us
to want to make plots in our viz.
Is the correct interface to this like
some really small signature like XYZ or
whatever and then like a a big plot argr
[ __ ] Is that it?
That's almost like object-oriented
programming [ __ ] though, isn't it?
Like making big strus where everything
is big strruct is very I mean that's
object-oriented programming with extra
steps.
Yeah, I think that you don't want to put
arrays into I think when you start
putting like variable length arrays and
[ __ ] into this truck for plot args,
that's when you're [ __ ] up, right?
Wait, if if you put like an array of
two, can I pass null?
You can't. Yeah, cuz Okay. because it
doesn't have a pointer.
I can just check them both against zero,
right?
That actually works.
So, let's like work on this.
If I were to do
If I just do float
expounds
to like this.
Oh, actually
hang on. I can do it. I can do it even
like this.
I just have to check him again. Zero.
Yeah, I just have to check them again.
Zero.
Yeah, the Python I'm like I've got too
much Python variable typing like
variable type sig in my brain here.
I think that would fix it though. The
only other thing is the color.
I guess if we just pass um
it's annoying, but we pass Cap as a void
star.
Um, okay. So, the font thing is because
there's a weirdness with Ray Lib.
There's a weird thing with Ray that
makes the fonts awkward.
Oh, you just mean put them all. I don't
like doing I don't really like doing
them all in the same line like that.
Okay. Wait, here's another question,
right?
Here's another question.
Do we
I don't like the idea of having to
collate a [ __ ] ton of render textures
either.
It could pass a bounds as a rectangle.
I wouldn't have to do any deferred
rendering that way.
int erase like this
size T.
Wait, what?
Well, I know size T major, but I don't I
have not used um I've kind of leaned
towards using the minimum number of
types possible.
So, anything that is not included as a
like anything that is not included by
default that I have to import for an
extra type
uh something totally different f uh
fiber.
instead of passing XYZ, I could pass
like a vertex like points or whatever.
It defines its own version.
That's funny.
I mean, I think this is like a minor
stupid detail. Oh,
You have to have the static size prim.
Okay,
I see.
Yeah, major. Apparently, I didn't
actually know that.
But this like again kind of just leads
me to like if you just use the simplest
possible subset, you don't hit these
problems, right?
If I just say [ __ ] it, the param is an
instar. Everything is like everything
that's not a static array is a pointer.
Let me see how we do this in like in
actual use. Let's see what my plotting
function looks like.
Should tell us something.
Let me see. We try to get these hyper
values
and then
we get a color map
Um,
the best code is the cleanest in some
sense by definition. And if the two
disagree, then you're just your sense of
aesthetics is off.
num m under env and train. Uh yeah, so
that's a little rough edge. My apologies
for that. XF8. So under env that's not a
required parameter. That's just
something we do by convention with uh
ocean environments because ocean uh
environments our first party puffer end
format is a vector format. So each
instance of a puffer end has many ends
internally and that is what that version
is. Uh the vec parameter is the number
of workers. So it's the number of
replicas. So if you set vec to four and
the n1 to 1024 then you're going to get
4096 total ms across four cores.
They shouldn't be called the same thing,
but it's actually kind of difficult to
come up with something accurate to call
them that would be different
without just naming one of them N, which
isn't helpful.
You know, I think my ideal interface
here would just be constructing a big
array of points, right?
Cuz you're going to calc the color map
anyways, right?
I guess the reason in my mind that I
don't fully like that is like what if I
just want to pass float XYZ.
But then what would you do for color?
That would only give you one color,
right?
Yet again, this is like Rayson being a
genius, right? Rayson handles this by
having a simple version.
He has like a few different versions. He
has like EX and Pro and stuff for his
methods.
I'm really starting to appreciate even
more and more just what a good dev that
guy is.
Num of workers pass my hardware core
count.
It threw an error. Uh so XF8 probably
the default vecum m in sweeps is more
cores than you have.
Yeah. So XF it's the defaults are set
pretty generous.
Do you not have um
Oh, I guess do I not even have it in
here? I actually fixed it in my dev
branch. If you see this, it's probably
set to like 16 or something. Just change
it in the config default to match your
number of course.
Never have come up with that scheme. But
like look, literally this is yet another
instance where Rayson just gives us the
answer to how to do this because this
guy's just like he's such a great
programmer
in so many ways.
Like look draw a line draw a line V draw
a line ex
so in a language where you do not have
the ability to overload one function to
have multiple signatures he just says
screw it and he gives you like some
short suffix and then he just puts them
right next to each other one line each
in a cheat sheet so it's like super
obvious that you can do it any of these
ways Right. And then like the it's like,
"Oh, but you should only have like one
input. Like there should only be one way
to do things." It's like, "No, you're
going to have your data in different
formats depending on what you're doing.
So, I'm just going to give you multiple
interfaces and you can use whichever one
like is going to fit the cleanest with
how the rest of your code happens to be
structured,
but it's not like three completely
different ways. It's just three slight
different formats on stuff. Some of
which give you like extras that you
might need sometimes.
And he never has big strus in here for
anything.
I think this is the answer, right? Is
that you just like
I kind of want to go read some of
Carmarmac's code for comparison.
Well, it's not going to just be all
Carmarmac, right?
It's also kind of dumb to be looking at
like literal 30-year-old code, right?
XF8. So in config /default,
there's a a setting there for the sweep
that has vecum worker uh vecum m. Just
set the max of that to your course.
And probably don't do 14. Do like
you can just set it to eight.
Oh, Quake. See,
wait, they have their own Wait, what?
Okay, the new line curly braces are
sending me
I have vanilla ice cream.
Uh
Some of the like,
okay, some of like the really like the
low-level dev just like coding practices
just drive me nuts. The new line curly
braces just drive me insane.
I think Rayson even does that [ __ ]
though, doesn't he?
the big file.
Yeah, this drives me nuts.
Why do people do this?
At least he doesn't do the eight space
indents.
I mean, this is just all a major
diversion, right? But
one extra line.
Okay. But like if you count the number
of extra lines like look. So, 1 2 3
5 6 7. There goes like a good chunk of
my screen space. Right.
go insane with clang format. I I have
always hated auto formatterers.
I care about stuff like should I write
my stuff this way or that way. I don't
care about having it automatically
enforced
cuz generally like
it would also help if most of the auto
formatterers didn't suck. I actually
don't know in C, but like in um
uh first like in black for instance,
black in Python, I hate that [ __ ] so
much because everyone's like, "Oh, look
now you can read the code cuz it's auto
formatted, but it's the worst auto
format ever.
It'll put like multiple returns on
different lines and [ __ ] It's insane.
I think that the correct interface
the correct like rich interface is to
have a point Right.
You end up doing some really stupid [ __ ]
in the process of trying to become a
better programmer. Okay, look. Did I
write this? I think I released this
article somewhere on X, didn't I?
I forget if I just put it on my website
or if I actually put it on X.
Okay. No, I didn't do it here. I think I
just put it on Did I put it on this?
I wrote some article somewhere that was
like I was basically try I was basically
writing trying to write C style code in
Python and because like I was trying to
write less bloated stuff and I didn't
realize that the language itself like I
didn't realize that the language itself
basically penalizes you for trying to do
that.
So, I wrote some really stupid looking
code for a while. Even put some of it in
Puffer in the process of like trying to
figure [ __ ] out.
Okay. Does Rayb have a point? Like, does
it have like point in it?
Just do point.
This is easy.
Code like in Python.
Yeah, we had this for a while.
So, I tried to make I had this namespace
thing which I tried to do. I did this in
order to try to make something that was
vaguely like a strruct.
Um, it was like a hybrid between a
strruct and a dict. And there were a few
other weird things as well. Um, where
do I have it in here?
I was not writing classes for a while.
I was doing some like weird [ __ ] where
I was basically like writing strrus
within a nit method.
So like I don't even know what the hell
it was.
But I was basically doing [ __ ] the way
you would do it in C, not realizing that
the language actively penalizes you for
doing that.
Well, I think I figured out how I want
to do it at least.
Uh, I'm going to just implement it and
you'll see if this makes sense.
Yeah, you can see if you think this
makes sense.
just be size, right?
size.
Do you need these points
or do we just want
It's actually very difficult to figure
out how a nice way to do this.
The only thing I don't need is
No Wait, I do need that pause as well,
don't I?
that this is obnoxious.
start and end.
I see.
That's annoying.
It's just an annoying array men
is all it is.
Literally just an annoying arrayman.
Well, we can do it off the points, can't
we?
Yeah. Yeah, we can do it off the points.
Hi, Major. I'm going to be doing this
all day tomorrow, too. We're going to
get this nice. It's worth spending some
time to make this good.
Are there guards for numbum ms?
Got one might make sure I'm not missing
anything.
Um I think the guard will just tell you
that you're wrong if I recall. So the
way puffer works is like you unless
you're trying like normal usage of you
messing things up, you should get like a
API usage error which means that you
screwed up and if you're hitting
internal [ __ ] it's like I screwed up. Uh
Jess, I'm trying to refactor this thing
nicely and it's actually very very
difficult to come up with a nice way to
do plots.
It's like this. Yeah, it's just tricky.
I don't know.
Um,
I think it'll just tell you you'll
probably get some API usage error, but
it's not going to like do it gracefully.
Yeah, because it gets scaled, right?
Get scaled.
But wait, if we just auto scale,
what happens if we auto scale?
I like this.
Let's
Do glyph
or vector 2.
So, let's just do it this way, right?
It's like pretty similar. No,
This feels a lot better. This is already
starting to feel better.
Even if it's going to take me however
the hell long that takes, this is going
to be good code.
What notification did I just miss?
Discord
We would kind of like to have
[Music]
We would kind of like to have the pixel
chords, right?
shader.
Right. And then this is basically this
entire thing.
yeah, this is going to end up okay, you
know.
and then it would just be like void
plot.
Oh no, wait. We can just do Yeah. Right
from this. This doesn't even need Okay,
this is fine.
Yeah, this is fine.
So, you just do two picks.
And then what we would do is we would
just check collisions right here.
Right.
Jess, there's not an issue. It's just
that the quality is [ __ ]
It's just like having basic pride in my
work
and wanting this to not just be a rotten
mess.
I think something like this is better
though, right?
because now we get this into
so we just take our thing.
Now arguably it's a little annoying that
we have to go through this point format
but there's no way I see around that.
I guess we could pass XYZ.
What's points have?
Yeah, but actually passing XYZ is not
even that convenient, is it?
Oh, we could very very easily make like
a two pix like float or whatever that
wraps this. Yeah. Yeah, we're good. This
is fine.
So, I think this is the right layer of
abstraction.
This is like lower level than you'd
expect, right? So, this just gives you
the screen cords back and then it lets
you do whatever with them,
I think what's going to happen is I'm
going to like finish this tomorrow.
But like let's say that I do this
refactor, right? What left? What is left
that's gross here?
Like there's some refactor in plot args.
It's not that hard.
I might fiddle with the axes drawing a
little bit,
but it's not bad. I guess the main
struct is a little iffy.
But like the rest of this gets a lot
better, right?
Yeah, we're just going to end up with
like plot and plotg
and then the UI will get fixed. We can
definitely
Hang on.
Uh it's so it's definitely going to take
some work, but I think we can we should
be able to get something pretty good
tomorrow. I don't know if I'll finish it
finish it, but we'll get something like
actually workable tomorrow if I don't
slack off on this.
And for reference, folks, this is what
we're building.
Hyperf RL dashboard. That looks pretty
cool.
Okay. Um, I'll be back 10:30ish
a.m. Eastern tomorrow.
If you want to support my work for free,
GitHub star, it helps a lot. Feed the
puffer star. If you want to get involved
with development, this is all open
source. Join Discord. We are advancing
RL right here.
And uh you can follow me on X for more
RL content, including my latest research
and my educational content. Thank you
all and have a nice evening. This
tomorrow, Saturday is going to be uh
ridiculous Perf optimization.